so he said if there isn't a deal and
breaks it we would need to look at a
different strategy and frankly we need
to have a new budget that set out a
different strategy for the future does
that concern you
well I think it's very clear that if we
ended up with a hard break suit then our
economy would be in real trouble and
that's got real implications for
people's jobs and livelihoods their
rights at work so I think he's probably
giving a warning there about the kind of
deal that we need but from the tc's
point of view neither No Deal normos
Mays deal are looking good
because what the priorities we think are
most important are jobs protecting jobs
protecting people's rights at work and
avoiding that hard border in Ireland to
protect the Good Friday Agreement
problem is listening to you say you know
you don't really like I don't know do we
don't really like the idea of Theresa
Mays deal but you can have to support
something aren't you I mean it may be
that you don't like the options but
perhaps would it be do you think more
responsible perhaps of the Labor Party
for example to back to reason may still
if the alternative was no deal at all
well the Labour Party can speak to the
Labour Party but from the tc's
perspective we've set out some very
clear tests I mean I was up in the
Northeast on Friday
visiting manufacturing firms talking to
workers and managers the northeast will
be one of the hardest hit areas if we
end up with a hard deal or no deal so
you know we're talking about real
manufacturing firms we're talking about
the future of our economy there is a big
difference between No Deal and Tories
most current deal which was well we know
yes a minute is a customs union so that
would be a big difference money fact we
don't know exactly what she's gonna sign
off from what we've said is look we'll
look at the deal we'll match it against
our tests if it falls short of our tests
then we think that mrs. May should go to
the country but the general election or
have a popular vote but one way or
another people deserve the final say on
that deal because it's their livelihoods
that are at stake
not much time that was there there
certainly isn't much so I mean I'm just
wondering very gradual is it realistic
to I think you get through those things
it has to be well we need if it seems to
be realistic but we can't have is being
presented with a Hobson's choice that
you can either have a really bad deal or
a bad deal that's not quite as bad
you know we've got we've got we need the
prime minister to go back to the drawing
board saying with this budget you know
we've been told for years that austerity
was necessary the truth is that our
economy has grown on average for the
last 10 years by 1.1 percent that is far
worse than all our major competitors
it's the worst decade in six decades for
growth in Britain so we need a new plan
and that has to be about investing in
jobs getting our NHS back on its feet
investing in skills and colleges how
crazy that we're cutting further
education at the very time when we're
expecting big transformations that work
because of digital we should be
investing in apprenticeships and skills
and local communities talking about
digital the other thing that I discussed
an interview with the Chancellor was the
high street and he acknowledged that the
high street would be getting smaller is
there something that you're concerned
about gee would you like to see action
against some of those bigger companies I
think there's going to be real change in
the high street but I think what people
feel really frustrated about is that
this government is continuing to give
away tax cuts to big corporations like
Amazon like Facebook hardly paying any
tax on the profits that they earn they
want on Amazon I actually asked Philip
Hammond if he shot to answer and he said
that he did do you do you shop I have
shopped it on his own do you saw what
I'm concerned about is the workers I you
know consumer someone why do you shop at
Amazon if you're concerned about workers
because we're trying to organize the
workers and the key point is is getting
Amazon to recognize the Union so that it
treats its workers fairly that's Amazon
well it's of course there are lots of
companies that people criticize but the
the fair thing to do the right thing for
that company to do and for the
government to support
is for to recognize the Union so that
those workers get paid and living wage
and treated decently like human beings
instead of what we're currently seeing
you know people too scared to take a
toilet break and being tracked
constantly by surveillance I mean that
is wrong so Amazon do doesn't deny that
only I need to sort point that out at
that point
I know these allegations and have been
made well they've they've certainly been
reported yes yes do you and it is no not
a point here about consumer spending
powers really a way to try and change
company's behavior is to you vote with
your wallet well here's something that
the government can do it can use its
spending power procurement to get
companies to do the right thing you know
the government spends billions in
procurements it can really help raise
standards but instead of bashing trade
unions through anti-democratic trade
union acts why isn't it empowering trade
unions to organize those workers and get
fair treatment and a fair deal at work
that's all that people want is a fair
hearing so if you were sitting in the
Chancellor's seat tomorrow if you had
the opportunity to deliver the budget
what would be your number-one priority
I think he's got to get wages and living
standards rising again and I tell you
our teachers our firefighters our civil
servants our prison officers all public
servants deserve a decent pay rise and
he could boost the national minimum wage
we've been calling for 10 pounds an hour
he could reverse those cuts to Universal
Credit and in work benefits and of
course our NHS and schools and public
service you believe austerity Zenden
well he's got to prove it I think the
Chancellor's got to prove it but he's
surely been given mission impossible by
the Prime Minister unless we get a
brexit deal that puts jobs first and I
think it's about people feel in this
country that we do need a national
recovery plan we need to get our country
fit for whatever kind of breaks it that
we need but we need to start investing
rather than cutting it's been a false
economy it's failed it's time to change
tack